[موسيقى]
لقد استغرق الأمر أقل من
50 عامًا وتطورت دبي
من ميناء تجاري هادئ إلى
المعجزة الحديثة للشرق الأوسط.
لديه أفق ينافس أفضل
هونغ كونغ
وسنغافورة نيويورك ، ربما يبدو العدد الهائل من
ناطحات السحاب ذات المستوى العالمي
مثل بارفا الجديد الذي
يحاول جاهدًا أن يتم ملاحظته وهو
يصرخ ، انظر إلي
، ثم أنظر إلي ثم أعتقد أنني لست متأكدًا من ذلك  الأمور التي
تحكيها هذه المباني عن قصة دبي ، واو ،
قد يناقش الخبراء المعماريون
جدية
الهندسة المعمارية في دبي ، لكن لا يمكنك
إنكار أنها مثيرة للإعجاب
من الخليفة إلى تلك التي تبدو
مثل
برجي بيج بن التوأم ،
فكل أفق وسط المدينة يقف
هناك ويقول
إننا  هنا
للانتقال من الصحراء إلى أن هذا لم يحدث
بين عشية وضحاها ،
فقد اشتمل على اندماج الحكام في
أراضيهم وشعوبهم ،
وقد اجتمع كل ذلك عندما
تم إنشاء هذا البلد
في 1  971
راميش شوكلا هو مصور هندي
كان حاضرًا عندما ألقت دبي دورها
مع ستة من shakedoms الأخرى
وأنشأت الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
مثل دبي ، لقد تغيرت تمامًا
هذا رجل في
الحياة شهدت عدسته نمو
أكثر من خمسة
عندما
وصلت إلى هنا في عام 1965 ،
55 ما كان عليه الحال هنا
أو هذا هو 50 عامًا بالأبيض والأسود ،
وصلت مع 50 لفة في كاميرتي
عندما وصلت لأول مرة ، لم
يكن هناك أي طرق مناسبة فقط
الصحراء شعرت أنها كانت  ليست مدينة حديثة ،
لا توجد مياه جارية ولا كهرباء ، لا
شيء كان هذا واقعًا بسيطًا للغاية ، لقد
بدأت في التقاط هذه الحياة القادمة
من مومباي
بأقل من دولار واحد في جيبه ،
وقد التقط راميش
صورًا لكل شيء من الحياة اليومية إلى
بعض المدينة
مناسبات بالغة الأهمية ، دعونا
نرى الصورة الأولى ،
فهذه هي أفضل مجموعة لدي
وهذه الصورة الأكثر شهرة
له وهي صورة رمزية لوقت إنشاء البلد ،
هذه صورة رائعة  نعم ، هذا
آمن سارديا ،
قالت روسيا كما قلت
مقطعًا دائريًا متقدمًا ،
هذا هو الشعار الوطني ،
يركز راميش شوكلا بشكل كبير
على العيون ويمكنك أن ترى السبب في
هذه الصور
للآباء المؤسسين حيث يبدو أن العيون
تتبعك وأنت تتخطى
أنا  لديك طلب ، هل ستلتقط
صورة لي ،
أنا فخور ،
شكرًا لك ، لقد حقق راميش نجاحًا مذهلاً
في فنه ، فهو يمثل مثالاً على
كيفية ازدهار البيئة هنا
لأولئك الذين يأتون بحلم